[Musique]
nous nions actions en ce moment mais
c'est marie jeanne qui a délaissé les
pompiers acquis en souffrance là nous ni
mis chez marie jeanne qui pak a occupé
comme il faut de ces étudiants qui là
bas qui nous ont des tees et de la lune
lycée marie jeanne qui kbc leur
rapprochement territoriale donc la donne
d'une émission marie jeanne qui kbc tout
bagage et y sociale bat à plate et puis
musicale et mettant l'eau l'agent andy
dans des drapeaux en dida des campagnes
publicitaires alors que l'agent tatp
servi à bon escient le drapeau c'est une
histoire un drapeau c'est une coupe 60
des couleurs sans capot là avec une
inconnue les pleurs les joies et les
souffrances et si on devient qu'il
s'agit d'avoir une balle est un sportif
ni balland les gars jouer c'est légation
jeunesse dans ces pays c'est dingue a
changé c'est cool et à quand tu es
sportif tu as besoin d'être côtier t'as
pas besoin d'être boosté tue parce qu'un
c'est avec mozart tu passes cassen
symphonies de mozart où tu passes casser
le pigeon blanc qui va qui va te donner
des pouilles
excusez moi l'expression ça qui donne
des couilles c'est quand tu te rappelles
ses ancêtres quand tu te rappelles des
gens qui ont souffert quand tu en suède
tu te rappelles de luminato fille là
l'esclave omer pleine sono m'a donné ce
monsieur nous fait cet affront non le
club a choisi rouge vert noir c'est ça
qui de la poule nous c'est ça qui
trinité nous et nous c'est des jeunes
pacifique mais nous excès des nukak cd
on a eu du respect pour ce monsieur est
certes à l'époque mais aujourd'hui ça
c'était avant
monsieur à marie-jeanne honte à vous et
dans tout voilà voilà pour ce qui se
passe ici
ally mc piano également que les pompiers
sont venus
manifester leur mécontentement au
président de la collectivité
territoriale de martinique